hey we're hearing Detroit it's me  meet you home goodbye to get our feet we  have to saw open and a perfect tip these  women got to be disgusted by my feet and  they'll kind of out there I feel like  I'm on a prank show but it's just  actually how my feet are over woman  we not a guilt to getting a 50% tip I  always  [Music]  there's one  [Music]  that's enough beat hit the gravel and  sit you walking like you get here though  that's what's really funny that's uh  they just show about to be killer cheers  to pedicures day drinking in Detroit  [Music]  and you know Detroit desires me feeling  the light on my feet walking around with  the microphone shilling the streets you  want beef  I'll give you soda and Pete what